we will talk about what will save the
world we can never say for world without
politics so what's your take on the only
anger among the people against the
political class well I'm Lincoln's day
there was even anger against the
political class and Lincoln himself in
one of his early speeches as a young man
attacks politicians saying I know to his
audience that you'll understand that
because I'm a politician myself so
there's always been this strain
particularly in American politics
skepticism about politicians we're in
one of these periods where there is such
skepticism but it runs deeper it's not
as deep as the crisis that occurred in
the 1920's 1930's in which which turned
into a profound crisis of democracy we
may be on the eve of such a thing where
people feel that democracy itself is not
only inadequate but also the obstacle to
resolving their problems and that order
is more important to them I don't
believe that'll ever happen in America
but we have such a figure in Donald
Trump who exploits disorder in order to
claim to be the authoritarian figure to
impose order this is a profound question
of beyond the United States that affects
the West it affects both conservative
parties and Social Democratic parties in
the United States it particularly
affects the Republican Party the
Democratic Party always has problems
with this party the Democratic Party
while it showed a split in its primaries
between Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton is
much more unified than the Republican
Party will see what the outcome is and
we will know it when we here at the
conference but there is still a problem
an intellectual problem a problem of
ideas a problem of culture particularly
in the European social democratic
tradition I believe this is in the
United States this is not the problem
for for American liberalism and that we
have many different traditions to draw
upon that are quite diverse